[Music]
Christian
welcome everyone to the table tonight
we're so glad to see you here want you
to know that you're not only welcome
here but you are celebrated here so we
have a couple of
announcements we are going to have a
trans 101 class and that's going to be
one week from tonight on January the
26th it'll be around 6:
PM it is after church so we will have a
class introducing you to one of the most
misunderstood letters of the LGB btq I
plus alphabet and that is the T which
stands for transgender as many of you
know trans folks are being heavily
politically attacked right now so this
is an opportunity to understand more
about who they are and how we can love
and support them let's be clear though
this isn't a class so much for Trans
people it's a class for the rest of us
to become more informed so you can sign
up by scanning the QR code whenever it
comes up on the
screen okay February the 2nd that is the
first Sunday and so we are going to
celebrate that this time in our Family
Life Center or the gymnasium out behind
immediately following the service this
time we're going to be sharing our
favorite soup
recipes so if you'll sign up bring food
by SC getting the QR code when it comes
up all
right if you notice we lit the
candles these candles are a sign of the
presence of Christ Among Us fully Divine
and fully
human so as we settle in for our call to
worship let's just all take a deep
breath let go of everything else we're
going to exit it that Kingdom of noise
and hurry and
productivity and we are going to enter
The Fellowship of silence and
Stillness and
simplicity we're going to enter a Sacred
Space a place for
prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold
Christ revelation of God heartbeat of
creation just allow The unforced rhythms
of Grace to find you to embrace you to
mend your
heart may we all come
home there it is all right would you
guys go ahead and stand with us our um
worship setup today is obviously a
little bit different than our normal um
but it honestly it took me back a little
bit to the covid days where we were all
in our own homes and Maggie and I would
often times be on a video camera with a
lot of you guys and it was very
um in a lot of ways it was it was lonely
because so many of us you know w aren't
in person together worshiping but there
was still some sort of sweet reminder
that God is with us in the little quiet
places he's with us when we're jaming
out and we have all our instruments and
the whole setup which I love it's so
much fun but tonight it's been really
special to kind of lean into a quieter
simpler like more strip down set so I
hope for you guys it's also a space
where you can tune in to what's going on
in your heart in your mind where you
could hear your voice singing out words
that hopefully will give you hope and
sustain you as we go into our week so I
just got I invite you guys in um let our
voices sing songs of Hope tonight let us
sing out together um as a community who
believes in a good God who loves us and
is with us even in the small places
[Music]
Be Still My
Soul Be Still My
Soul be still and know my God is
here be still my
soul Be Still My
Soul be still and know my God is here
all that I need to know is this you are
a good God the maker of heav Heaven
calls me here you are a good God and
your heart beats in my chest you are a
good God all that I have to do is you
are a good
[Music]
god sing I won't be
afraid I won't be be
afraid I won't be
afraid I won't be afraid my God is here
he makes a way he will make a
way he will make a way he will make a
way my God is here all that I need to
know is this you are a good God the
maker of heaven calls me him you are a
good
God and your heart beats in my CH you
are a good God all that I have to do is
rest you are a good
[Music]
God you gave me your eyes you gave me
your heart your spirit flows through my
veins you you gave me your eyes you gave
me your heart your spirit flows through
my veins you gave me your eyes you gave
me your heart your spirits through my
veins me your eyes gave me your heart
your spirits through my veins you gave
me your eyes you gave me your heart you
had a plan right from the start I know
who I am cuz I know who you are you are
a good God all it I to know is
this the Mak of Heavens calls
[Music]
me all that I need to know is this you
are a good God the maker of Heavens
calls me you are a good God and your
heart beats in my CH you are a good God
all that I have to do is
you are a good god yes you are a good
God you are a good God you are a good
God you are a good
[Music]
God all right our kiddos are dismissed
to go to their classes and your teachers
will meet you over by The Doors
thank you so muchy
[Music]
abti thank you thank
you and we are going to transition into
the prayers of the people so if you guys
would follow along on this screen over
here um and we'll read the parts in red
aloud together and then in that space in
the middle let's lift up the things that
we're carrying into this room together
tonight
Jesus for the city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
when you walk into the
room Everything
Changes Darkness starts to tremble at
the light that you bring when you walk
into the
room every heart starts burning
ands sit here at your and
you we worship
you sing we love
you we love
you we'll never stop can live with
without you
Jesus we love
you and can't get
enough all this is for you
[Music]
Jesus
Jesus when you walk into the room
sickness starts to vanish every hopeless
situation ceases to exist when you walk
into the
room the Dead begin to rise cuz there is
Resurrection Life in all you
do we love
you we'll never stop can't live without
you
Jesus we love
you we can't get enough all this is for
you
[Music]
Jesus
Jesus Jesus
[Music]
Jesus come and consume God oh we are you
permission our hearts are yours we want
you we want
you come and consume God all we are give
you permission our hearts are yours we
want
we want you sing that together and God
we are give you permission our hearts
are yours we want
you oh Jesus we want
you so come and consume by all we are we
give you permission our hearts are yours
we want
you we want you
we love
you we'll never stop can live without
you
Jesus we love
you we can't get enough all this is for
you
Jesus
yes Jesus
[Music]
Jesus so set a fire down in my soul that
I can't contain I can't control I one
more of your God I one more of your God
set a fire down in my soul that I
contain that I control I want of your
God I want more of your
[Music]
God more of
you see no
place No Place I'd Rather Be No Place i'
ra be no place I'd ra be than Here In
Your Love Here In Your Love No Place i'
Rather Be No Place i' Rather Be No Place
i' ra be then Here In Your Love Here In
Your Love set a fire down in my soul
that I can't contain that I can't
control I want more of your God
I want more of you God so set a down in
my soul that I contain that I can't
control I want more of you God I want
more of you God so set a fire down in my
soul that I can't contain that I can't
control I want more of your God I want
more of your God so set a fire down in
my soul that I can't contain that I
can't control I want more of your God I
want more of
your set a fire down in my soul that I
contain that I control I want
more I want more of you God
[Music]
I am set free
oh I am set
free it is for
Freedom that I am set
free you broke my chains of sin and
shame and you covered me with
Grace end my life with your Holy Fire
you cover me with
Grace you are the head the reaches out
to
say I am set free oh
I am set
fre it is for
Freedom that I
am
free sing that one more
time I am set
free I am set free oh
it is for
Freedom that I
[Music]
am and yes Lord we are
grateful for your grace and For Your
Love Yes Lord we are great grateful for
your grace and For Your
Love Yes Lord we are grateful for your
graise and For Your
Love Yes Lord we are
grateful for your grace and for your
love
you are the hand that reaches out to
say I am set free
oh I am set free
oh it is for
Freedom that I am set
free I am set set
free I am set free
oh it is for
Freedom that I am set
fre sing we love
you we love
you we'll never stop we can't live
without you
Jesus we love
you we can't get
enough all this is for you
[Music]
Jesus Jes
God tonight we remember what it is to
return to a Heart of
Worship one that's just here to be in
your
presence a heart that's just seeking the
love of a God who found us who rescued
us who sees
us a God who forgives
us a God who sticks with
us God would we be faithful
followers who aren't just here for the
high moments who aren't just here for
the V
victories but a people who seek you and
invite you into even the darkest places
the hardest challenges of our life the
moment when it's all falling apart God
would we seek you would we find you in
the midst of
it would we listen for your
voice would we invite you in
speak to us tonight
God we want to hear
[Music]
you we want you to keep transforming
US changing us more and
more into the heart of God to the hands
and feet of Jesus who bring light and
life in Jesus name I pray
amen thank you guys would you turn to
the people around you and say hello and
then Brett will get us started on our
message
all right now we're good grace and peace
welcome welcome to the table really glad
Finley's giving them a round of applause
that was beautiful huh it was really
great great worship set um yeah I like
the Simplicity there's something about
kind of stripping back occasionally and
you know um something to that so um yeah
I just want to welcome welcome you all
into this space and those join us online
you too um love you all don't forget to
get your uh communion stuff toward for
towards the end of the service and um
yeah just anyone here tonight um who is
um maybe it's your first time or just
your first time in a while um we're
really really glad that you're here and
um we are kind of as a church we in the
season of uh it's known as Epiphany and
so you kind of have this whole
trajectory if you followed um you've
been with the table for a while you know
we mostly follow the church calendar and
it basically the church calendar kind of
follows basically the Life of Christ
right you have um kind of the season of
Advent which is like preparation for the
birth of Christ and then you have kind
of Christmas and I think it's known as
technically Christmas tide and uh the
celebration of the birth and then we
have the season of epiphany which is
sort of the beginning of Jesus ministry
there's a lot of um scriptures and
things that are around like Miracles and
Revelation right thus Epiphany it's sort
of you know the the bursting forth of of
Christ in the world and uh you have that
and then you go into the season of lint
right which is kind of leading um into
like discipleship and then we're kind of
coming to the way of the Cross and then
you've got um Good Friday and then Holy
Saturday and then Easter right and then
the whole season of Easter and um so you
can kind of see right where you're just
sort of flowing through um through kind
of his life so that's where we are right
now is in this kind of um the beginnings
of um his life in Ministry and um so
with that in mind the the title of my
message tonight is um new wine and we're
in this this story right it's the the
first very famous Miracle of Jesus
though it's a kind of unique one and
that you know it's not like someone's
healed or something and uh yeah but it's
it's it's
fascinating all right
audible so um yeah so John Chapter 2 uh
verses 1- 11 which reads on the third
day a wedding took place at Canaan in
Galilee Jesus mother was there and Jesus
and his disciples had also been invited
to the wedding when the wine was gone
Jesus mother said to
him they have no more
wine woman why do you involve
me Jesus replied uh my hour has not yet
come right in other words like you're
trying to nudge me to do this miracle or
you know whatever my hour's not yet come
and uh his mother said to the servants
do whatever he tells you
nearby stood six Stone water jars the
kind used by the Jews for ceremonial
washing each holding from 20 to 30
gallons so Jesus said to the servants
fill the jars with water so they filled
them to the brim and then he told them
now bring some out and take it to the
master of the banquet they did so and
the master of the banquet tasted the
water that had been turned into wine he
did not realize where it had come from
though the servants who had drawn the
water knew then he called the bride
bridegroom aside and said I love this
part everyone brings out the choice wine
first and then the cheap stuff right I'm
paraphrase a little bit but after the
guests have had too much to drink but
you right basically like after
everyone's lost their discernment you
know it's like now I don't I don't even
know what I'm drinking you know that's
okay but he's like oh not you you know
you have saved the best till now what
Jesus did here in Canaan of Galilee was
the first of the signs through which he
revealed his glory and his disciples
believed in him so tonight um rather
than kind of the a popular way to kind
of read scripture especially in the
early days of of Christianity was more
kind of um symbolic and spiritual
readings and such and so uh I'm going to
give you more of a a metaphorical kind
of symbolic um spiritual reading of this
tonight interpretation of it so uh I
want to start here I um personally you
can all have your own opinions
personally
I think one of the great preachers in
America right now is named Pastor Brian
zond out of Word of Life Church I've
mentioned him before sometimes I quote
him like quite often and uh out of he's
in St Joseph Missouri and especially his
kind of more recent stuff the last kind
of I don't know 15 years or so um now
before that wasn't this hasn't always
been the case so he started off as a was
known as like a Word of Faith preacher
so kind of the uh you know name it and
claim it and uh if you you know if you
have the faith God wants to make you
rich you know and all that so he kind of
started off there and but although he he
started his church when he was very
young like 18 years old or something so
that was just kind of the the movement
he was in so he did that and then
eventually kind of started to transition
towards a more kind of like mainstream
like Evangelical kind of Faith
um but but something happened um after
many years of that it was by this time
he was now in like his mid 40s he said
um something began to kind of shift in
him a certain kind of restlessness a a a
kind of holy
discontent and he he just sense like
God's kind of calling me to to something
new you know he said it was strange
though because like outwardly uh
everything was going great he I mean he
was very popular so big old church big
budget big building you know just a
whole he's like a religious success
story or something uh and yet he he knew
inside it was like something's
something's off
so in his uh kind of a bit of a kind of
a me Memoir he wrote titled Water to
Wine he said these words he said' I was
weary of the tired cliches of bumper
sticker evangelicalism I was
disenchanted by a paper thin
Christianity propped up by Cheap
certitude the politicized faith of the
religious right was driving me crazy I
was yearning for something deeper richer
Fuller but let me say it this way I was
in canaa and the wine had run out and I
needed Jesus to perform a
miracle have you been
there you've been in a place where the
the wine starts to run out you've been
in that place where you have a certain
like version of faith of belief
of of a certain theology maybe even
didn't use that term but at least in
retrospect now you realize that's what
it was you know I was like yeah I had
these theological beliefs and yet
something like well at that time you
believed it at least at one point you
believed it so deeply like maybe even
you were all in on it but at some point
something starts to shift and it starts
to feel thin watered down and you're
left thinking I need a miracle have you
been
there I have it was 2007 I had just
completed about four years or so of uh
being a youth
pastor and I eventually transitioned out
of that not so much BEC it wasn't really
about the theology
um or a lot of beliefs at least kind of
what it came to be later a lot of that
was just honestly I was just kind of
burnt out and um and I think I did have
some discontent with kind of the way of
doing church I it's sort of a side
tangent but I think youth ministry in
many ways is sort of um I think in a lot
of ways it's kind of broken in this
country it just it started off in a good
heart you know like let's get something
for the young people make it cool and
attractive and but then it just it's
like you keep trying to Max that up you
know to where now it's like let's give
away Nikes anyone want to come to church
we'll give you Nike you know it's just
weird like what are we doing you know so
anyway okay so that's a side side CH so
I was just so I I leave and but that
that kind of sent me on a journey I
think once I wasn't a pastor anymore I
felt a little a little more freedom you
know to like okay I'll just need to read
the books I need to read and think the
thoughts I need to think and pray the
prayers I need to pray you know so it
kind of sent me on this journey and I
really quickly started to realize like
that man as in in ways I could kind of I
was at that time kind of preaching you
know big game and and such I could I
could say you know may the presence of
the Lord fill you you know or something
I was a little bit more charismatic back
then and and yet I felt like I was kind
of barely like in my own life in my own
heart and mind actually barely
scratching the surface of
that I I could say oh the Lord is love
but then my doctrine of like hell just
seemed to be in total kind of
contradiction to
that I I believed like the holy
scriptures were just like
absolutely pure and perfect perfect and
without
error um and yet I avoided all sorts of
passages in my preaching and teaching
and even my own reading I because I just
didn't know what to do with those verses
you know just and it and it I couldn't
make any sense of it I uh I would tell
people I remember telling people as a
youth pastor like oh young you know you
have nothing to fear from science you
know and yet I was like so scared of the
theory of evolution it really freaked me
out out like I was just like oh my God
just it messes up my whole reading of
Genesis and I messed up my whole reading
of Genesis well then it's like my whole
doctrine of God I just you know just
freaking I was freaking out
um and even in ways like the politics of
it all I say you know kind of sense at
least like oh God's on our side but then
as I kind of surveyed the landscape that
just started to sound like I don't know
Hollow and weird and it's like I
questioned it you know like is God
really always on our side I don't know
it seems like maybe we're not so much on
God's side sometimes you know and in
other words I was just I was in
canaa I was in Cana and my wine was just
it was running out I needed Christ to do
a miracle I needed new
wine now I do think there's a little bit
of danger in going down this track my
point isn't so much to like demonize a
specific theology I know because of
Ron's Journey it can really sound like
that about evangelicalism and you know
that Theology and such um and because
that quote I shared but I I really want
to name like it's it's not I'm really
not so much saying like oh that that
particular theological movement as a
whole oh that's just crappy wine it's
it's it's too I do think there's
elements within every Church tradition
every theology you know I mean like
there is good and bad in it as we'll
actually get to later in the message um
so it's not I'm not trying to paint with
too broad of brush Strokes you know to
say I think we could get really reaction
AR here at the table you know like thank
God there's all that crappy old wine all
those beliefs and now you know now we
found the perfect wine you know or
something and it's like well is it that
simple you know so that's not really my
point isn't to say any particular
theology is just bad wine cheap wine $3
Trader Joe version wine um some of you
like that I don't I like okay I like
some Trader Joe it's pretty good um it's
it's just it's more to say that like the
theology the of God um the religious
perspective we once had at one time it
really was genuinely new wine for us you
know really well God really was using
it but we lock in right and we say it
was once new wine and so it must always
be and then suddenly it's
not and that's where we got to keep
journeying we got to we got to discern
we got to know when that wine is getting
old right so this isn't about getting
judgy it's it's really more about
learning to discern um when that wine
has run out um for us so tonight what
I'm going to do I'm going to share with
you five keys to finding new wine and uh
something that can make your pallet
happy so all right first key number one
be
thirsty be thirsty there's that old
saying you can lead a horse to
water but can't make drink right and and
that's kind of me tonight I mean I can
say like oh there's this new wine out
there you know and but obviously if
you're in a place you're like I don't
care you know oh okay there's there's
not I can't you know do much with that
um so I would say kind of the the kind
of prerequisite for everything else I'm
going to say is got to assume a certain
thirst right a certain
curiosity um now on the upside though if
you do find yourself thirsty um Jesus
did promise The Sermon on the Mount
Matthew 7 seven ask and it will be given
to you seek and you will find knock and
the door will be open to you that's tell
you that verse has been a Lifeline for
me because sometimes it's like a journey
to the new W you know and I was like I
don't know if I'm Gonna Make You know
there's there's a certain faith in like
okay God will meet me just keep seeking
keep knocking don't give up you know um
okay so that's that's first if you're
thirsty Christ promised that the holy
spirit will lead you you'll find what
you're looking for key number
two be
eclectic be eclectic again I think a lot
of us are kind of coming from traditions
where they're pretty Limited in terms of
um not necessarily teaching us about
what I call like big tint Christianity
you know and saying like hey there is
new fresh good wine to be found in all
sorts of wings of the church and you
know like at least I don't know about
the tradition you came from mine was
like pretty limited like we got the good
wine and everyone else is like a bunch
of liars you know and and I think that
can kind of limit us again where we're
not used to opening up and thinking you
know kind of broadly um I had this well
growing up I was always really mystified
as to um why old people of course when
you're like eight you know is like I
don't know probably anyone over like 22
years old you but I guess I'm was
thinking in this scenario more like like
my grandparents and stuff you know like
genuinely older folks and I remember
thinking I was so mystified as to like
why old
people um like liked old music like why
they all liked old music and why they
dressed like the olden times and why
when you walked into their house it kind
of had that like a certain smell and a
certain you know mustiness and like the
style of it was you know at a style I
don't know about you but um I think of
like walking into Old Folks homes where
there's like that sofa with the plastic
still around it you know and like don't
sit on that sofa that's the fancy sofa
did anyone have this experience or I
don't maybe y are like I have no idea
what you're talking about that was like
why because they were wanting to protect
that fancy soofa but the weird thing
about the sofa was it looked like it was
700 years old or something like is that
did you find that in the ancient
Egyptians tombs or something you know
like um but but now it took me a while I
guess only for me to like actually get
older to start to realize like
oh the the reason they were like that is
because at one time that was the cool
music that was the trendy way to
decorate your house that was the cool
car and the clothing and the you know
what I mean or like that was just how it
was so in essence all you have to do to
get out of step with the times is just
remain with where you are right and this
is already me I'm like 40 years old I'm
like just cold play is where it's at
that's all I need is Cold Play you know
like just I'm just like Frozen in 2003
or something and you can see where right
where this happens to us um and I think
something similar happens to us
theologically where again we just kind
of lock in and we're like well it's just
such and such radio preacher for me
you know like I had a a friend few years
back who was like really into Joel
ostein and uh don't be judgy there can
be some good one okay um but every time
I walked into his house it was like jool
oin was on and he would be like oh I
love Joel you know and I was like you
sweetheart um and but that was his thing
right and for like 10 years it was just
he's locked in and um I think this is
what happens is we just get sort of
captured you know it's like well I'm
just a Richard Roar guy some of you are
like you are captured by Richard roar I
know I am I'm stuck with Richard or for
like 10 years um but you know or I'm
just it's Jin hat maker for me you know
or it's the
liturgists or or sometimes it's kind of
a a genre of theology you know it's the
it's the white Progressive theology for
me you know or it's it's it's it's queer
theology or um you know whatever what
yeah we're just we just get locked in
you know and uh and and it's new wine
for us at one time and it's good and we
find life there but eventually we might
find the wine running
out and it's at that point we've got to
keep moving this is why I say be
eclectic right in essence kind of like I
think of it like this it's the New
Year br take
out like try something new that everyone
say new with me new isn't that it's like
e it kind of sounds like ew like E I
don't want new you know it's it is
strange how we just get comfortable
don't we you know I mean just like well
this is who I know and I just like them
and that's the that's the author I read
That's the podcast I engage that just do
that's just my people and I just stay
there and you
know break out open up
because if you're thirsty for new wine
you can't keep going back to the same
sources for something new right so don't
be surprised if inspiration not striking
just like a I thinking to keep this
analogy going like a somaler you know
someone who's trained you know with
wines and such like like how many wines
are they familiar with like oh my gosh
it's just a thousand right that's how
you develop your pallet and get a really
Broad taste and a a kind of sense of
what's out there and available right and
how do you do that you got to open
yourself up smer can't just be like it's
Mero that's all I do it's Mero you know
like no no you got to expose yourself to
to many different wines so okay so
that's the the second one be
eclectic um third be open be open human
beings are um well I'll I'll frame it
like this once you say like okay I'm
going to step out I'm going to do this
we are by Nature very bad
listeners we are by Nature very bad
readers I don't mean like we read too
slow or something I I mean
um if it is new if it's different if it
disagrees with something or pushes on
something to us we're like no
Noom that you know like this is and this
is just who we are right we're it's okay
like we're all kind of quivering nerve
endings and you know feeling a little
defensive
and and it is it's really hard to kind
of be just be um open to what God might
be doing one one way to put it is as
you're kind of starting to go on this
little theological Journey this year you
might just ask yourself like have this
question in mind um what's the truth in
what they're
saying what's the truth in what they're
naming right again our tendency is to
say how are they wrong how are they off
how do I disagree where do I disagree we
have um I've mentioned we have a little
reading group um that meets on Saturday
mornings at Rosas and the trick as we we
just read like half a chapter a week of
whatever book we're going through and I
I almost always have to suggest like hey
let's start by sort of naming like what
do you think the author is getting at or
what did you like enjoy or what do you
think they're on about like what do they
write about here you know because it's
amazing how quickly we want to jump to
the critique you know I me like well let
me tell you where this author was
completely out to lunch and and I
disagree and you know we just kind of
naturally go there so we're going to
have to kind of push back on that and
we're going to have to learn to be open
another way to put it would be just to
say uh eat the meat and spit out the
bones think I've said that before in a
sermon just eat the meat and spit out
the bones in other words find the good
and then you're like oh that's not so
good okay that's fine just let it go you
know mean like in other words don't
judge the whole thing based on like
oh you know and then yeah
oh one I'll give one last example of
this like in kind of for the theological
nerds in the room you know um so in like
Progressive e Christian circles St
Augustine is often like
Boo Boo he's like kind of the father of
Calvinism and there's like a whole thing
you know just Bo August original
sin you know um I think that's a good
example where that is um
well I think that's
stupid like in essence to be clear I
don't love like everything augustin's
ever done oh Lord I'm not I'm like the
opposite of a calvinist you know um but
uh like for example his book confessions
like sort of the almost the beginning of
the modern Memoir comes from G I mean
it's in it's incredible it's incredible
like yeah so in other words it's not as
simple as just like that person bad you
know you know mean that theological
movement bad this good like that is so
unnuanced you know so got to kind of
open up open up all right fourth fourth
key be
Discerning be Discerning this may sound
a little bit in contradiction to my
previous point I'm like be open and I'm
like no be Discerning you know um but
it's it's not so much a problem to solve
you know it's a tension to manage you
got to you have to think both these
thoughts at the same time um you're
going to have to write discern well what
is meat and what is Bones I think a good
kind of rule of thumb here um is to to
discern whether the spirit's really
speaking to you through something it's
just to ask like is this kind of leading
me towards the fruit of the spirit am I
feeling like a certain draw towards a
love towards a joy a peace like is
that's the that's where the good stuff's
happening you know and or vice versa if
it's sort of beating you down condemning
you making you feel like trash okay
that's that's usually a sign like maybe
maybe they're off there you know in that
um that area you notice I I do quote a
lot of like monks and a lot of people
from like the contemplative wings of the
church and honestly this is why because
in my own reading those are the voices I
have found who personally for me um are
are the most helpful in creating the
fruit of the spirit in me you know for
me they have been new
wine but maybe not for you
you know I mean and and that's fine
that's where that's where you can be on
your journey and uh start to find that
that wine that's resonating with you uh
Fifth and finally be
practicing be practicing what I mean is
ultimately the new wine of Christ isn't
it's not so much just like you know
ideas and Theology and abstractions the
you know the the idea of doctrines and
all that ultimately
um it it pushes us towards forms of
living we might say that like the
ultimate goal of Christianity isn't
actually Orthodoxy right belief but
orthopraxy right action I think of St
Paul who talked about without
love ah it's just a bunch of idea you're
just a a noisy gong and a clinging
symbol even if you know all the
theologies and all the stuff you know uh
but without love it's you know not much
as happening there so we don't want to
be that those people you know who read
all the books and do all the all the
intellectualizing but then it never like
gets kind of embodied in US it just
remains at the level of
information so
um okay so you say Brett well this is
all some very good ideas what do you
want me to do here's what I want you to
do pick one it could be a book written
or audio it could be a YouTube lecture
it could be a podcast or some other long
form media emphasis on long form no no
Tik toks which I heard got banned and
then I heard was like coming back I
don't know I'm confused about what's
going on with Tik Tok but no T this is
not you know a 60-second t I'm following
a new person on Tik Tok like no no
Instagram reals whatever no no um choose
something
long and uh and something from a fresh
perspective this week um something
that's like unexpected something you've
like never engaged before and then go
ahead and read it or watch or listen to
it you know um for at least 15 minutes
each day until you reach the
end now you say Brett I don't even know
where to begin
friend you are talking to the right
person you just you just email me text
me I will I've got ideas for you um but
I'll also throw out a few here in
closing so um if you want more academ
I'm going to suggest all books because
it's me sorry you got me as a pastor and
that's how it goes so um academic books
if you want more that that you know
academic stuff being consumed economics
and Christian Desire by William kavanau
a black Theology of Liberation by James
con written I think in the early 70s or
mid 70s F
incredible
incredible um life together by dedric
Bon Hofer Confessions by St Augustine
God sexuality and the self by Sarah kley
all awesome non-academic works the way
of the pilgrim uh the it's kind of a
work of Eastern Orthodox um Faith uh the
practice of the presence of God by
Brother Lawrence Julian of norwitch the
showings by mirabi star did a sermon
series on her a few months back the
inner voice of Love Henry now and that's
a great like kind of a devotional um oh
beautiful writing be he's he gos from
the kind of Catholic Christian tradition
um and then bad theology kills by Kevin
Garcia he's a um kind of writing from a
queer perspective and really some really
good stuff there so um in short
church if you're willing to be diligent
I trust the holy spirit's going to lead
you to new lifegiving
places to new wine in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen
so on the night Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples
and at that meal he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said take
it and eat this is my body broken for
you and then he held up a cup of wine
and he said this is my blood it's shed
for you whenever you eat this bread
whenever you drink this cup remember
me so as we come forward to the table
tonight as we take in that the body of
Christ the blood of Christ may this be a
moment of reconnection a moment moment
of um Epiphany and inspiration where
we're drawn to follow Christ more deeply
and beautifully in our lives so the way
we're going to go about this we'll just
start here in the front row and we'll
just kind of work our way back row by
row just forming a line right here we
practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then you are free to
do that regardless of exactly which like
wing of the church you hail from or
whatever um you're welcome to do that
the red is wine the white is grape juice
and then finally you can just partake
whenever and however you'd like some
folks like to take right away others
like to kneel up here at front um some
return to their chairs to partake but no
one will lead you through the exact
moment of partaking so this is the table
not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have TR tried to follow and you who
failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
tonight we're going to close with a new
song um it's called middle of it and
I've been listening to this song for a
while now and I'm really excited to
introduce it just because the words have
been a comfort to me um just because
sometimes you can be so focused on the
old wine that you're leaving and
rejecting and that can be a painful um
kind of like when you're leaving
something
you're kind of focused in on the
negative you know but when you're
searching for something new and you're
opening yourself up to the new that God
might be bringing or showing you um
there's life in that there's um
oftentimes finding other people who are
also on that Journey you know there's
Community um leaving is lonely but
finding is like
freedom and so anyway this song um I
hope you guys enjoy it if you would like
to stand and sing it you're welcome to
if you want to sit down with us you're
also welcome too because that's what
we're doing um but anyways um yeah just
listen to these words and take them
[Music]
in we are
leing crumbling
buildings full of dust and full of
judgment we are
leaving violent
teachings from those who refuse to learn
from the best of
us we are
leaving crumbling
buildings full of diance
full of
judgment we are
leaving violent
teachings from those who refuse to learn
from the best of us we are
leaving crumbling
buildings full of dust and full of
judgment we are are
leaving violent
teachings from those who refuse to learn
from the best of us
[Music]
we are
seeking a holy
healing full of Hope and full of
justice and I've got a feeling that
we're in the middle of it I've got a
feeling she'll see us to the end of it
we are
seeking a holy
healing full of
Hope full of
Justice I've got a feeling that we're in
the middle of it I've got a feeling
she'll see us to the end of it we are
seeking a holy healing
full of
Hope full of
Justice I've got a feeling that we're in
the middle of it I've got a feeling
she'll see us to the end of
[Music]
in the
midle in the
middle in the middle of
it in the middle of
it in the
midle in the middle
of in the midle of
[Music]
thank you all so very much for joining
us if you're a visitor we'd love for you
to scan the QR code or pick up a
visitor's card and fill it out so that
we can answer any questions and get to
know you a little
better uh we can all use more relational
support and spiritual connection
so here at the table we do that through
the meetup groups and again you can scan
that QR code and find a group that fits
your schedule and your
interest a generosity is a key aspect of
a life of adoration and worship if the
table is your church home or you would
like to support us we invite you to scan
the QR code and to give financially or
you can also visit the table tx.org
and now I'd like to send you into your
week with this
blessing you can stand or sit you can
hold your hands out in a posture to
receive or you can just open your heart
to these
words you are a child of
[Music]
God yes you are a child of God
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day so as you go into
your week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved that you are
worthy and you are respected and
accepted Just As You Are and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone that you
come in contact with be blessed and have
a good week and we'll see you here
again we Are
seing Holy
healing full of Hope
open full of
Justice I've Got a
Feeling we